i'm your host pete heggseth and tonight
we start with one very important
question
where did the 15 000 illegal residents
of bidenville go
because it's become painfully obvious
that the white house has no answers for
us as they rushed to clear out the third
world camp they created in del rio texas
here's how circle back saki broke down
the numbers today
1401 haitian nationals have been
returned to haiti 33 206 haitian
nationals have been moved from the del
rio camp to cbp custody or to other
sectors of the united states border to
either be expelled via title 42 if
possible or placed into removal
proceedings therefore there remain less
than 5 000 migrants in the del rio
sector
sounds very official
now i'm no mathematician but those
numbers don't add up
at all
15 000 were there
minus 1400 returned to haiti
minus 3 200 in so-called removal
proceedings we'll get to that
and 5 000 still in bidenville
that leaves roughly 5 400 5400
unaccounted for illegals
that's not a rounding error where are
those 5
400 illegals who used to be in
government custody
or even if it's 4 000 or 3 000. fox news
correspondent peter ducey tried to find
out earlier today
there are 15 000 migrants under the del
rio bridge saturday if you add up the
ones that you say were expelled or
released it's less than five thousand
say there's five thousand that are still
left where's everybody else when you
talk about how some of these people are
being placed in removal proceedings that
does not mean removed correct that means
they're in the process of going through
a removal proceeding so that we can
it can go through the process our
immigration process that's long been in
place
well done peter well that wasn't much of
an answer was it there jen as it appears
no one in removal proceedings is
actually being removed
if individuals cannot be expelled under
title 42 they are placed in removal
proceedings as you referred to that may
that may require them being placed in
ice detainment facilities or it may
require being them being given a notice
to appear
ah so saki couldn't even be honest about
that because the administration
is not actually issuing the more
enforceable notice to appear instead
border patrol is telling fox news that
illegals are quote mostly being released
with the notices to report
at an ice office rather than notices to
appear there's a difference the
preference for ntr's report which takes
just 20 minutes
rather than ntas which take more than an
hour to process
so it's all a word game as bill
mollusion also points out saying
ntr is a request to check in with
immigration within 60 days
nta gives an exact date they must report
so there it is it's a request to check
in
that's what the white house considers
removal proceedings so when jensaki says
removal proceedings she actually means
released
removal proceedings equal released
it's all a word salad
now to be clear that means the vast
majority of the illegal residents of
bidenville
will soon be illegal residents of the
united states
that's what it's come to
kindly asking illegal immigrants to turn
themselves into an ice office on their
own time frame pretty please
and we know from past experience that
the vast majority will never do this
and the administration knows this
they want more illegals
and it's not just in del rio biden's
looking to spread the crisis all along
the border
as dhs is now sending bidenville
residents to el paso laredo the rio
grande valley and even flying some to
tucson arizona for processing well i i
should say removal proceedings
which i really mean released
with a plane ticket to the destination
of their choice maybe your hometown
so while biden and his open border
handlers are making it impossible for
border patrol to actually i don't know
control the border
maxine waters is comparing a secure
border to get this
slavery
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
cowboys
with their reigns again
whipping
black people
tell the story
about what is going on and let people
know that they're trying to take us back
to slavery days
back to slavery days now i want to mock
it
but it's actually really offensive to
every descendant of a black slave who
was actually whipped by a slave master
of course the democrats turned to racism
it's their go-to move
but don't worry fellow americans al
sharpton went to del rio texas today so
he could get to the bottom of it just
don't tell the actual people who live
there
without your hatred to make sure that
people get treated
he was shouted down for the sham artist
huckster that he is
he tried to talk and couldn't
al sharpton might try to fan the flames
of controversy by going to the border
but at least he actually went
which is more than we can say about joe
biden
yesterday the white house had no answer
on whether biden has ever visited the
border not just as president but ever
and they're still silent on the topic
but we at fox news have not stopped
digging and while finding zero evidence
that our near octagerian president has
visited the border in his entire life
biden did head to guatemala when he was
vice president to address
get this
the root causes of immigration
boy does that sound familiar
guess he never found the answer to that
one because it's never been a real
solution
joe biden had no problem calling the
border a crisis back in 2014
but now that it's his mess
of course he's nowhere to be found hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else